hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain a
2012 british american science fiction
movie called prometheus the film is the
fifth entry in the aliens franchise
serving as a prequel to 1979 science
fiction horror film aliens
make sure to watch until the end because
there will be a bonus fun fact about the
movie
on prehistoric earth as a huge alien ufo
departs from the planet a humanoid alien
stands beside the waterfall and drinks
the dark liquid causing his body to
disintegrate as its remains cascade into
the waterfall the alien's dna triggers a
biogenetic reaction
later in 2089 two archaeologists
elizabeth shaw and charlie holloway are
doing an observation in a cave when they
discover an ancient star map and
consider it as an invitation from
humanity creators or they call it as
engineers
in a large spaceship the ship's crew
makes the long journey sleeping in
status while an android robot named
david monitors their voyage
after two years the ship suddenly stops
and says that they have already reached
the destination threshold meaning that
they have arrived at their destination
the first crew are known as mission
director meredith vickers has awakened
and is approached by david commanding
him to wake up the entire crew the crew
then is presented a visual recording
showing sir peter weyland the ceo of
whalen corporation the man who gathered
the funding to construct the advanced
research vessel named prometheus to find
the engineers the boss then introduces
the archaeologists who explains that
archaeological digs from all around the
world indicate the same pictogram
showing then worshipping giant creatures
pointing into a star
from that they then found a planet which
is capable of sustaining life named lv
223 the planet that they just arrived at
the prometheus lands near a large
artificial structure in a valley
with six hours left of the daylight the
survey team starts to suit up and heads
inside to explore
using mr fifield's advanced detector
drones they are able to picture the
whole grid of the structure
they continue their expedition deeper
and then discover a room with a hole
inside it where the air is breathable as
something is generating an atmosphere
david on the other side discovers green
slime which contains many particles and
makes some electric sound
he also presses a sequence of buttons to
the wall activating a recorded hologram
which shows several engineers in
spacesuits running from something
the survey team then chases the hologram
and finds one of the engineers falls
down in front of a door whose body is
still there the carbon reader indicates
that the body has been laying there for
more than two thousand years david
attempts to open the door and they
discover a room full of well-arranged
cylindrical vases containing black
liquid and paintings all over the wall
suddenly the control unit detects
incoming silica storms and the survey
team immediately starts to fall back
they also bring the dead engineer's head
and david packs one of the vases the
team removes the helmet from the
deceased engineer's head and manages to
shock the head back to life momentarily
before it explodes into pieces
shaw then takes a dna sample and
analyzes it discovering that the
engineer has the same dna as humans with
a perfect match
david investigates the stolen cylinder
and discovers the black liquid within he
secretly takes a drop of the liquid and
intentionally infects holloway with a
substance by giving him a glass of
champagne unaware of what is within his
body he engages in sexual intercourse
with shaw
on the other side fillfield and
melbourne who were left behind continue
their exploration in the cave they come
across a pile of engineer bodies while
they are suddenly told by the control
unit that a detector drone reading a
life form from the west but it suddenly
disappears claiming that it's just a
glitch having known that they decide to
walk towards the east and arrive at the
previously visited room
they spot something slithering in the
river of black liquid and suddenly a
snake-like creature pops out the
aggressive creature then attacks
melbourne
fillfield tries his best to help his
mate but it ends up breaking his arms
and killing milburn it also sprays
corrosive fluid towards milburn's helmet
destroying it and burning his
face the next day the crew returns to
the structures while david suddenly
stops and turns to another direction
he then discovers a room containing a
surviving engineer kept in a status he
attempts to press the buttons causing a
chair to swivel out and commencing the
engineer's hologram
an engineer is spotted playing a flute
and suddenly a huge space map appears
highlighting earth as its next
destination
on the other side the crew finally finds
melbourne's corpses but holloway's
condition is getting worse as the side
effect of consuming the black liquid
they then rush back to prometheus
vickers is already waiting for them
preventing holloway from getting into
the ship
equipped with flamethrowers she finally
burns him to death
on the ship shaw is being examined by
david who reveals she is three months
pregnant that's quite odd as they only
had the intercourse 10 hours ago
feeling something is wrong with it she
insists to get it out immediately but
david suggests putting her into a
cryostasis until they reach earth while
she is going to be taken shaw fights
back manages to run away and performs a
self surgery with a med pod
surprisingly an octopus like alien is
extracted from her belly shaw manages to
escape from the pod and traps the weird
creature there
the control unit detects that filfield's
monitor just popped up and finds that he
is actually standing outside the ship
with that monster face he becomes much
stronger and attacks the ship crew
[Music]
they finally managed to take him out by
burning him with the flamethrowers
on the run shaw finds out that weyland
is still alive and was on the ship all
the time
he explains that meeting the makers or
the engineers could help him to cheat
death in some way
but shaw urges that they must leave
because the engineers are not what they
are thinking they kill people
he refuses as they have been so close to
meet them and this will be their only
chance
while dressing up shaw meets the
prometheus captain yannick who
speculates that this planet is not their
home and the structure was part of an
engineer military base that lost control
of its biological weapon the mutagenic
black liquid
vickers warns the ceo that he will die
if he goes to the structure
there it also reveals that the old man
is actually her father
they then returned a part of the
structure david had visited before
coming across thousands of the
cylindrical vases
given the live stream from shaw's camera
the control room discovers that the room
is actually a spaceship
david reveals that the engineers were
heading to the earth to destroy humanity
because sometimes to create one must
first destroy they attempt to awaken the
surviving engineer as he wakes up david
speaks to him to explain what whalen
wants unfortunately the engineer
responds by decapitating david killing
weyland and team
shaw manages to escape but the engineer
touches a ball of green energy
activating the spaceship and bringing
out a weapon like chair
he sets the course back to earth to
continue his mission to destroy humanity
and the ship starts taking off on the
other side shaw urges yanuk to prevent
the alien spaceship from flying even
further
convinced by shaw the captain manages to
stop the ship by crashing it with the
prometheus killing himself and his
remaining crew
only vickers who manages to escape from
the ship ejecting in an escape pod
as the ship collides it starts rolling
in a perfectly straight line killing
vikers as she fails to outrun it it's
quite funny to see viker's inability to
run in a different direction barely
surviving shaw makes it direct
prometheus and finds the alien offspring
she had removed previously now has grown
to enormous size luckily it is still
trapped in the medical bay
surprisingly david is still alive and
reveals to her that the engineer has
survived the crash and is coming for her
moments later the engineer forces open
the ship's airlock and attacks shaw but
she manages to open the medical bay's
door and unleashes the alien offspring
after a struggle the engineer is subdued
by the gigantic creature which thrusts
an ovipositor down the engineer's throat
killing him
david begs for shaw's help and claims
that there is still another ship and he
could fly the ship
without an option and desperate for an
answer shaw then recovers david's head
and body from the wrecked engineers ship
with his help instead of flying back to
earth they are heading for the
engineer's home world hoping to find why
they created humanity but only to
attempt to destroy it later
the black liquid was originally created
by the engineers as a biological weapon
with the purposes to wipe out the entire
planet especially earth it's actually a
lethal mutagenic pathogen composed of
billions of small microorganisms they
were kept in the cylindrical vase due to
its unstable nature at ambient
temperature as we saw in the previous
scene where the crew force into the room
and disrupt the atmosphere the black
liquid begins to react we also have seen
throughout the movie that the creatures
infect the hosts causing them to mutate
turning them later into more aggressive
and stronger creatures
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching